تدور رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو مؤثر لام جزائريه فاجئت ابنها الذي
يعمل ضمن عناصر الامن في بطوله كاس العالم
بقطر واحتضنته بالدموع بعد غياب دام لاكثر
من 18 شهرا وهكذا كان اللقاء الاول بين
بين الام وابنها نتابع
[موسيقى]
مشاهد متداوله لمعركه بالايدي تحت قبه
البرلمان التركي خلال مناقشه الميزانيه
تحولت الى عراك وتلقى فيها نائب ينتمي الى
حزب حزب العداله والتنميه الحاكم لكمات
على راسه نقل على اثرها للعنايه المركزه
وهو في وضع حرج
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مقطع فيديو كناري في الهشيمه على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعيه لشبان ينقذون سائقا
سائقه مركبه باعجوبه على طريقه افلام
الاكشن قبل سقوطها من منحدر في اربيل
[موسيقى]
سيده صينيه زي فتح حملها لتهريب اجهزه
كمبيوتر واجهزتي ايفون اوقفت السلطات بعد
الاشتباهي بعدم صحه حملها خلال عودتها من
مكه فقط لفتح حجمه بطن السيد الكبير جدا
انتباهها مراقبي الجوازات وبعد طلب مرورها
وبعد طلب مرورها من خلال ماسح ضوئي ادرك
المراقبون ان السيده ليست حاملا وانما
كانت ترتدي ما يشبه بقانون
البلاستيكيا وحاله السلطات السيده للقضاء